comment est ce qu'on fait concrètement
pour gérer problèmes d'eau les
différentes solutions il yad'abord
effectivement l'innovation technologique
qui permet d'apporter à un coût assez
restreint de l'eau dans différentes dans
différentes régions ou de d'exploiter
loti petit peu existé qui peut y avoir
de la question du commerce également le
commerce international est une des
grandes façon de gérer la question de
l'eau notamment le commerce agricole par
exemple l'élevage consomment beaucoup
d'eau et donc les pays qui sont au
stress hydrique ont plutôt tendance à
importer leur viande 1 plutôt que de la
produire localement parce
qu'effectivement il vaut mieux apporter
de l'ordre de la viande qui a été
produite dans des zones avec avec une
grande quantité d'eau élevés plutôt que
de la produire localement en tirant sur
les sur les sur les réserves qui a vous
avez marqué mais qui a aussi rappelé la
question de d instabilité politique et
des guerres en syrie oui c'est
effectivement un problème on sait pas le
résout nous aujourd'hui on peut toujours
dire qu'il faut résoudre le problème de
la guerre en syrie mais aucun d'entre
nous au tour cette table n'a la moindre
idée de comment il faut le faire
effectivement il ya des problèmes de
gouvernance
effectivement les problèmes politiques
et ce sont des problèmes d'organisation
qui font que qu'il faut qu'on arrive
qu'on a des problèmes d'eau vous n'avez
pas de pays démocratiques avec une
économie de marché qui fonctionne bien
avec une gouvernance qui fonctionne bien
qui est un problème d'eau les problèmes
d'eau et sûrement des pays qui sont non
démocratiques sont des lipides dans les
pays qui sont en guerre qui sont à
l'instabilité politique qui sont avec
des gouvernements corrompus et qu'ils
ont des sujets des soucis de gouvernance
donc ya pas de problèmes techniques
il n'y a pas de problèmes de rareté
mondiale d'eau marque les 10 et une tête
d'épargné mais on a tous sont disposent
tous de l'équivalent de 700 piscine
olympique de 12 par personne par humain
c'est le steam vous rapporter le nom de
2,2 de la quantité d'eau douce pour
chaque humain c'est la quantité qu'on a
donc on a largement assez d'eau douce au
niveau mondial simplement effectivement
il faut qu'on s'arrange pour mieux
desservir en eau les zones qui sont
attention et c'est essentiellement
malheureusement des problèmes et des
questions politiques locales plutôt des
problèmes macro mais dans les pays
démocratiques et qui fonctionne bien on
a effectivement un système de tri qui
fonctionne
[Musique]